breaking here at four three people now
injured take a look at this video after
the driver of a vehicle drove right into
a business business that is in the
southwest part of town thank you so much
for joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce
and I'm Denise Valdez now we're told the
car crashed into a Great Cuts just
before two this afternoon that business
near Durango and windmill as we take a
look at the map here Ryan Matthey joins
us live from the scene with what
happened Ryan
[Music]
that three injured into Southwest Valley
crash you can take a look over my
shoulder here that tow truck just
arrived to pull it out from the building
the white car that you see on that truck
there just moments ago was directly into
the front door of the member Great Cuts
and color that is down here just off
Windmill and Durango it seemingly looks
like the car just went through the front
of the the front door it doesn't look
like any of the surrounding businesses
have any damage or little damage as
there is any now we don't have a lot of
information right now from police all
they do report to us at the moment is
that there are three people who were
taken to UMC for non-life-threatening
injuries were being kept pretty far back
I don't know if you can see from here
but police are not allowing us to go
speak to the different businesses that
surround it now we've called those
businesses many of them have not
answered some of them have answered yet
but are just like you and meek just
trying to figure out a bit more
information about what happened here so
we're going to be staying on site as we
get more information from police about
everything leading up to this crash but
for the time being reporting live here
near Durango and windmill Ryan Matthey 8
News Now